hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts the teen brain insights from
neural imaging I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminars presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinar and those offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
c/e button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of the web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Jay deed dr. gede
was a postgraduate fellow in the Child
and Adolescent Psychiatry program at
Duke University School of Medicine from
nineteen eighty nine to nineteen ninety
one and then accepted a position as
clinical staff fellow at the child
psychiatry branch of the National
Institute of Mental Health and I mhm he
was promoted to senior staff clinician
at the ni-mh in 1997 and he was named
the chief of the brain imaging section
in 2001 in 2010 he was appointed adjunct
professor at the Johns Hopkins Bloomberg
School of Public Health dr. geet is
board certified in general psychiatry by
the american board of psychiatry and
neurology with added qualifications in
geriatric psychiatry and by the American
Academy of
in adolescent psychiatry please refer to
dr. deeds image in the top left corner
of your screen for more information
about him I will now turn it over to dr.
gede for his presentation
hi everyone hi everyone my name is je
today I'm going to be talking to you
about the teen brain and how its
changeability makes it a time of
vulnerability but also of enormous
opportunity when I tell people what I'm
going to be talking about I tend to get
some unsolicited feedback such as it
should be a very short talk you mean
they found one isn't that a
contradiction of terms or along this
theme of search for the elusive my next
talk will be about the Loch Ness monster
but what I hope to convince you is that
the teen brain is a not broken not
defective it's as it should be this
notion that teen brain is an oxymoron
not as an example of biology gone wrong
is reinforced in several books such as
the primal clean um get out of my life
but first could you drive me and cheryl
to the mall now I know why Tigers eat
their young and more straight to the
point yes your team is crazy but teens
do have brains and with modern
technologies such as magnetic resonance
imaging we can for the first time look
under the hood at the living growing
brain and what we found is that the teen
brain is not broken in fact it's it's
pretty amazing if you remember nothing
else from this presentation what I hope
you remember that but the adolescent
brain it's not a broken or defective
adult brain it's
half-baked it's not just simply between
a childhood and an adult brain it has
been exclusively forged by evolution to
have features that are different than
the brain of a child and different than
the brain of an adult but these features
have served our species very very well
and so and what I'd like to convey to
you that the teen brain is a really
amazing in terms of its ability to learn
to adapt to change across all social
mammals adolescents have these three
features increased risk taking increased
sensation seeking which it first sounds
very similar but they're they're stars
are subtly different and a move away
from parents toward peers these are I
think are deeply deeply rooted in our
biology because they're not just humans
all social mammals exhibit these three
behaviors cause it's always speculative
to have a evolutionary why reason but
one of the leading thoughts is that
these features allow us to leave home
which is a very rational decision in
many many ways our parents love us they
support us they feed us they protect us
it's very irrational to want to leave
that environment but by doing so then
there's more chance of meeting other
people of less inbreeding which has
genetic evolutionary advantages so it's
not so much of a moral right or wrong
it's just that it works better if if the
genes are more diversely and integrated
if there is greater very very
variability so we wouldn't be well
served to try to eliminate these
features in terms of their so deeply
rooted in a biology but we want to keep
them non-lethal we want to harness these
these behavioral tendencies for for good
and minimise the risk for dangers in
terms of car accidents on firearms
drugs a lot of these new risk factors
that weren't really there when our
brains were evolving so this is a from a
museum smithsonian museum that's close
to where i used to live before we're
being 22 san diego that's a really thick
wonderful exhibit and as part of this
was looking at the change in human brain
size the last big change is about 500 to
800 thousand years ago and this is a
subtle but important point to make what
was behind the big change was not the
harshness of the climate but the change
in climate itself and so before seeing
this i was taking wow you know what got
really cold only the most robust amongst
us could survive only the most clever it
could find a way to stay warm just to
find food to be able to reproduce but
but what this is showing is that it's
not the harshness of the climate but the
rapid change itself and so everybody
listening through this presentation had
teenage ancestors whose brains were very
good at adapting to change and this is
in contrast to our very close on genetic
cousins but Neanderthals and Neanderthal
brains were actually about thirteen
percent larger than human brains and
they survived in some very difficult
conditions and a surprising amount can
be learned from studying fossilized
teeth exactly in some ways redundant
because everybody is a fee to this
moment are fossilized in the sense of
being calcified mineralized cells but
teeth like trees have growth rates and
for trees it's called dendrochronology
and you can map out the growth each year
in terms of years that had a lot of
water good growth conditions have larger
rings years that there was less rainfall
let's grow shorter means that you can
get very precise a correlation amongst
different trees in terms of identifying
back years of growth and climate but you
can also do this for teeth and pee
thoughts also have growth rings and it's
a very good indication of maturation so
as long as you are having these growth
rings as long as the the teeth are
growing then you're still maturing and
when the growth of ink stop that's an
indication of maturation so if you find
a 12 year old Neanderthal fossilized
truth but in a cave he'll be likely to
be with his children not his parents and
and this is a framed and often as
surprisingly rapid growth in the
adderalls but I think that's the wrong
way to look at it what's surprising is
the protracted growth in humans were the
outliers we're the ones that are very
different than any other species a very
long time of being protected by our
parents on thirty percent of college
graduates live back at home for at least
a year and not criticizing that they're
very good financial and other and other
reasons why that that may be the right
thing to do but even even before you
know modern college and education things
compared to any other species we have a
long time protection of our parents it's
one of the most distinctive things about
humans and in general across mammals
even across avians the longer their
period of protection from parents the
better the brain in terms of more
complicated food gathering strategies
more complicated social structure more
complicated problem solving behaviors
let us de trade up but we have this very
long time where we can in a sense keep
options open are the human brain can
adapt to incredible different
environments we can live in the North
Pole we can live on the equator you know
almost everywhere in between we can even
live in outer space for a little while
with technologies that our brains have
developed and so it's this ability to
adapt and change that was so essential
for our survival the NFL brains didn't
have
this adaptability their tool use hardly
changed at all for about 200,000 years
and of course there was in reading we're
all a little bit neanderthal but one
that I think the most critical
differences between Neanderthals and
humans is teenagers human human
teenagers having this very stretched out
period where the brain can figure out
what is the demands of this environment
is that to stay why I'm to find calories
in a frigid cold environment is it to
find out what fruits and vegetables are
edible in a warmer environment when just
phenomenally adaptable and I think that
adaptability is really being put to the
test now with the digital revolution
digits aren't your fingers and toes but
London zeroes in terms of and how much
of our our day is spent interacting with
ones and zeros as we're doing at this
moment and so I've been very interested
in this interface between the digital
revolution which I think has had huge
changes on the way that we learn the way
that we play the way that we interact
with each other that revolutions often
are overused hyperbole but I think when
we look back this really will be seen as
a revolution in human history and the
amount of time that we spent interacting
with screens and digital devices so I've
been very interested in this interface
and in the digital revolution and
adolescent brain evolution I focused on
adolescence I'm not because adolescence
start the only ones affected
two-year-olds could meaningfully
interact with iPads and they also swype
like plants and refrigerators and stuff
but but in but you know people beyond
adolescence I'm also usual a lot of the
digital technologies but adolescents are
sort of in this sweet spot there they're
young enough to embrace that the chain
that the changes but they're old enough
to master the technologies it's even you
know right 14 year olds and often run
circles around even computer science
teachers in their school so that I think
this is a very active
field right now in terms of looking at
the digital technologies and how they
affect the lives of teens of health and
illness there are potential for inner
recognition intervention and improving
lives but it's a very very fresh in and
active area can often that the
fundamental question is is this too much
in terms of all the time with
smartphones and so much of our lives
interacting with screens and like most
interesting questions the answer is it
depends what it depends on and how it
depends and let it depends on is the
stuff of science and that details of the
paper but I wanted to look at it with a
little more nuanced in terms of the
three domains of learning play and
social I'm so the upside to it learning
is phenomenal in terms of immediate
access to the best minds on the planet
tedtalks Khan Academy that it might not
have sort of gone this way in terms of
free access and and almost a bit with
access but it has it's just there's so
many things that you can learn online a
click click away as an opportunity to
meet each student exactly where they're
at developmentally personalized
instruction and to me it and when when I
talk to my teenagers I am frustrated
they're not more amazed at that you can
find out so much online more so than
kings and queens and present government
even 30 years ago we have access to way
more information than at any time in
human history on that there's a concern
about the signal to noise in this vast
ocean of information how do how do we
find the truth from from the lies how do
we harness this information to it to
solve problems which i think is one of
the fundamental goals of education and
the change that's needed an education we
need to be a pair of students for their
future not the present of their parents
and and it's um it's hard it's hard to
change this educational systems each
generation that gets old and older it's
harder to adapt to the new technologies
so but this I think is one of them the
fundamental challenges of our time
there's also a concern that the
information is a mile wide an inch deep
that people just skim the headlines that
it's also mediate and fast nobody do and
um that could be the case but but there
there's not a lot of evidence of that
that you know it's happening if you want
to dig deeper you can actually do more
efficiently you can follow links you can
you know you can get access to other
papers um so that you know that maybe
some of a risk but it's not a given and
people i think underestimate how often
people do dig deeper and can can use the
technologies to really improve the
scholarship this is again this is about
big controversy in terms of whether this
immediacy is dampening our skills of
patience and persistence and and whether
this will be a generational difference
the other aspect is multi tasking and in
terms of that not only are people have
almost 11 hours of the day with them
what screen time about thirty percent of
the time people are doing more than one
thing so you do your homework but you're
checking your Facebook status let's
increase my tunes there be ice cream
surely a lot of things at once and so
this has been another area of active
research of whether this multitasking is
having an effect on on how the brain is
developing whether it's a skill that can
be learned and improved and the jury
still out i mean that um it seems to be
clear that you can't do a whole bunch of
things as well as you can one thing and
this idea of a multi tasking tax from
marcel Justin at carnegie mellon that
you pay you pay a price in metabolism in
time in inefficiency but it's but it's
not a great tax and we can
um look at a presentation on the
internet and maybe glance at some emails
you do do a few other things we do it
all day we and most people multi-task a
lot and how often you need to be just
purely mono tasking focusing on doing
your absolute greatest work um it might
be nice sometimes but it's probably um
rare that we have to really um we had
our one hundred percent best for many
many tasks but this is this is a big
area of investigation in terms of can we
harness the brains plasticity in the
younger years can we learn to multitask
better or is it better to focus on the
mono tasking aspect of learning how to
focus on one thing through meditation
through training to practice the other
aspect of the digital revolution is play
these games aren't really really really
really fun um and the rmv on these has
now surpassed militaries some of the
most clever computer scientists in the
world are working on on games yeah there
used to be the complaint that it'll turn
people into couch potatoes that the
games are too passive no longer true
with Wii Fit connect these other devices
you can be as physically active as you
want to adjust the settings for you
don't even need to hold things anymore
the technologies can look at where your
head elbows and knees and joints are and
interact with you in without having a
hold of the devices or to wear special
clothing it's just there phenomenally
engaging to the brain in terms of they
play the brain's reward systems you know
master surely we have this sort of
steady trickle of dopamine for novelty
people in bank lines about 30 seconds
eighty percent of people will have a
phone out you know checking checking
their phone that we we aren't very good
at boredom anymore and again I'm not the
judge that as good or bad but it's so
different we our brains are used to
having nearly constant
relation if we don't have access to it
we get a comfortable it feels unpleasant
and whether there's a Down type of this
in terms of sometimes that boredom
generates creativity and imagination and
other things so like almost everything
I'll say about this it's you it's it's
nuanced and terms up but you know maybe
you can have a better imagination with
the aid of the internet and another
other input so I think that one of the
issues is like is you know this is kind
of turning the brain to Moises or
something wrong about having really fun
games and easy access I don't think it's
so much that I that is just they're so
fun that it'll take time away from home
work that there's only so many hours in
the day almost always that the games and
the freedom to surf the net on your own
terms is going to be more fun than
homework exposure to sex and violence um
it's bifidus should be hard not to come
across sexual content internet violence
as well so the amount of time with
violent video games has gone up fourfold
just since 2002 the degree of violence
is limited really you know only by our
imagination but do kind of over-the-top
bum and so there's a lot of concern
about this eroding the fabric of our
nation that the implications of this and
so it's been surprising that real-world
sex and violence are at all-time lows in
the u.s. so unwanted teen pregnancies
all-time low sexually transmitted
diseases among adolescents forty seven
year low abortions amongst adolescents
as well forty seven year low as what as
is real-world violence in terms of since
they've been measuring all-time lows
this is the only force the other way we
all over this of course you know this is
you know the cause of this so so it's
generally puzzling in terms of its yeah
they're not violent they're not you know
mugging you on the street because
they're in their basement
like I isn't there may be there may be
some truth to that but it could be more
profound that that people are working
through sacks and aggression in in
virtual environments that and aren't
hurting other people and these again is
it part of the human condition the prime
directives we need sometimes aggression
chipper to stay alive to protect our
family our resources our loved ones and
we need you know sex Tabaka the species
so you know the idea isn't to eliminate
things these drives but you to keep them
non-lethal and um and to make optimize
the good and minimize the bat but but
it's been interesting in terms of that
the concerns of how each generation that
changes it usually cause us alarm
amongst this is a generation going back
to dime novels TV radio this has always
been the concern that that something
horrible is going to happen from from
these technologies the other big aspect
is social interactions so about
twenty-five percent of traffic is porn
twenty-five percent is social media
things like like like facebook yet I
think it fills a profound human need in
terms of what people really like to you
know connect socially I'm to these
technologies and one aspect of this is
this idea of a more global community
where were young people we're watching
the same internet videos cats you know
playing piano or whatever that you know
the current ones are but a lot of
prejudice and is as ignorance we don't
understand other people other cultures
and with all of us sharing a lot of the
same content we see that we're much more
like than different people love their
families they want to do well about
their parents and society they may have
different foods and religions and dress
and cultures but fundamentally we're a
lot more like than different and then
this has been borne out in studies that
we're 17 to 21 year olds are much more
globally minded less provincial they are
aware of what's going went on in the
world and this could be a very nice run
upside to having a world of shared
content um the the downside in terms of
that there's just something but wrong
about interacting so much through
screens that we have evolved to be
together to smell the same things to
feel the same things very subtle facial
expressions that a lot of our brain is
dedicated to social skills we need to
get along too just to stay alive in
terms of that's what our species did
well we're not that being a strong the
fastest but working together in groups
and to stay alive and to reproduce but
that is just like a it's very different
in terms of an end are there going to be
implications of spending so much of our
time in such a different way
cyberbullying is a big concern again
it's it happens it's tragic you know
when it does um but it hasn't brought
you know there was bullying before the
internet there is a take a growing
recognition of the accountability that
what happens in Vegas stays in Vegas but
what happens on the internet is is there
forever I'm in terms of that if there is
bullying as well its prey ssible your
countable floor so now not not not to
minimize that aspect I think it's
another sort of area of ongoing study
but that this genie is out of the bottle
we're not going to you know stop people
from using technologies and the internet
and so you know fundamentally I think a
lot of the concerns come down to this
this notion that as my grandmother would
say you know it's just not natural
there's something odd about spending so
much time with these screens um that we
weren't i evolved to do this the
counter-argument to that is now in
readings not natural either readings
only about 5,000 years old so throughout
most of human history nobody read and
now a lot of us spend a lot of our
waking hours with words or symbols and I
mean 10,000 years ago and
terms of hunting or gathering berries
and now this time really it's so
different and that's really my most
fundamental point that that what the key
is is that the adolescent brain is
changeable that it can make these
incredible adaptations and this change
ability is a double-edged sword and it
does create some some boner abilities
but also opportunities and much of my
career has been spent I'm trying to
understand this changeability how the
brain actually changes what influences
these changes in terms of diet exercise
second languages drugs second music
sports all the things that might
influence grain development in health
and illness okay and the study design is
pretty not pretty nigh creative admitted
Lisa so you have people get their brain
scan now to actually in the womb but any
time long life have people come back and
about two intervals nothing magical
about that you're sort of pragmatics and
existed a lot of studies are kind of
these these two intervals and people
come back and we do whatever the most
current brain scanning is get DNA from
blood saliva or skin cells and see how
people are doing at home at work at
school doing behavioral assessments
during clinical assessments so these
numbers are ever-changing um but uh over
10,000 scans about half of them healthy
typically developing youth and half of
those twins another half from clinical
populations such as ADHD autism tops
offending I depression 25 other other
illnesses that we're looking at so this
is I just a joke slide showing why MRI
is better than cat-scans because you can
put a captain an MRI but but really what
is the advantage is that MRI scans don't
use radiation so not only can you scan
helping children you can scan repeatedly
over time and this is really launched a
whole new era of adolescent their own
neuroscience so if you take rain out and
cleaned up a bit and put it on I guess a
white tablecloth it would look like this
but to an MRI machine it just sees boxes
of gray or white these boxes are about a
millimeter on a side you can make them a
little smaller if you have a more
powerful magnet or how people spend
longer time in the magnet but for most
of the literature we're looking at a box
of about about a millimeter cubed which
contains maybe five million synapses you
have we're not sort of looking at the
kitchen table of the neurons talking to
each other it's more like we're looking
at City as we're coming in from a plane
that we can say oh here's the business
areas shopping centers residential we
can see certain things but we have to be
careful not to over sell on what can be
done with the neural imaging there's a
response impatient to do that too like
let's make you know humans simple and
those colorful pictures and movies and
try to get around all of the incredible
subtlety zuv the human condition in
terms of the legal system no lie MRI
just do a brain scan to tell if
someone's telling the truth or not using
neural marketing and stuff and and and
in general maybe this will come up the
questions I think it's better than a
coin clip we can do a little bit of that
but it's not nearly as as far along as
people think so I just want to briefly
summarize on this results of me over 25
years of you know how does the brain
change from birth through childhood to
adolescence into adulthood and one of
one of the surprising aspects was that
the brain doesn't mature by getting
larger and larger my first grade the
veins already 93% of adult size and that
was not obvious to us at well we'll
watch the brain grow and if it's this
big oh now you can derivative of this
big algebra now this big in calculus and
so is almost a kind of pointing
some ways a lot you know we're going to
be watching us seven percent change over
30 years it's not going to be very
dynamic and that actually you know how
to help the brain doesn't change that
much it reaches its peak size in girls
by about 11 and boys by about 14 so it
doesn't mature by getting larger and
larger how does it mature then one of
the ways is that it becomes more
interconnected and the way that we can
study how the brain is connected one
aspect is white matter and so white
matter is this fatty insulating
substance from these cells called
oligodendroglial which is sounds like a
big word with many branch glue and like
an octopus these these cells send out
this wrapping material more and more
about one to two percent a year in the
fifth decade for women the fourth for
men so but definitely throughout
adolescence is blue line is is white
matter for males gratis white matter for
females and this insulating material is
is not very subtle and it really really
helps some so what happens if you look
really closely between committees our
little hot dogs the electrical signal
can hop from gap to gap and this really
speeds things up a hundred times faster
with with the Milan and the other part
is that the way this works is gates open
up and positive ions outside can then
rush pasta and through the previously
logged gates into the cell axon and
that's how the signal is propagated a
lot of the energy of our of our bodies
about twenty twenty-five percent is
spent reloading these membranes and so
now we only have to reload at the gaps
instead of all along the way so the
cells are ready to fire 30 times faster
that's a huge increase in bandwidth a
hundred times of speed 30 times to
reload three thousand fold increase so
this is responsible for many
behaviors of humans and things that we
can do uniquely uniquely well but it's
not just pedal to the metal you know
optimizing speed it's all about the
timing because information in the brain
is all about the patterns I'm in terms
of the networks and the firing and so
this the myelin helps not just the
faster the better but in exquisite
timing of how different parts of the
brain can communicate so a brain cell in
the front part of the brain will need to
get information from the visual system
in the back from the auditory and aside
from the word systems in the middle and
all this information has to arrive at a
very tight window 50 millisecond window
51 thousands of a second adds up all the
A's all the nades decides to do to fire
or not it Sam it's amazing it ever works
that the timing is this so so critical
but a trade-off is is that as the myelin
is laid down it releases molecules that
prevent the plasticity prevent further
arborization and this change so that's
the trade up as we as we go through the
teen years we have fewer but faster
connections the connections that we use
that lead to good outcomes are
reinforced strengthen the connections
that lead to bad outcomes are physically
removed but it is trade-off between
specialization and plasticity overall
it's one to two percent but there are
certain parts of the brain whether it's
like dynamic that could be fifty percent
within one year and other areas that are
slower but this also gives us notion of
sensitive or critical periods where as
we understand where different parts of
the brain are being most actively
changed this is when the environment may
have its biggest impact which has
educational and interventional
implications but in general the brain
becomes more interconnected through the
through the adolescent years it's not
just white matter it's looking at under
the microscope to look physical
connections EEG coherence is when one
part of the brain is electrically active
what other parts are active along with
it
a same thing for fmri activation
functional MRI which looks at blood flow
in the brain but when blood flow is
change in one part of the brain what
other parts of the brain are increasing
or decreasing related to that there's
this idea of cells that fire together
wire together dating back to the lab in
the 1940s one of the maxims of
neuroscience but now we also see that
selves a fire together wire together
grow together there's another aspect of
connectivity you could say what parts of
the brain are affected by the same
genetic or by the same environmental
factors so all of these aspects of
connectivity increased during
adolescence and are being studied now by
what for me is a relatively new type of
math called graph theory and graph
theory looks at everything as a node or
an edge and this uh dates back to 400
years of boiler the great mathematician
describing these nodes and edges and
this idea of a small world network I
don't have that the audio working for
this but this idea of a small world and
what was surprising was that this math
that arose from how computers could
survive a nuclear attack how you connect
different computers around the world
that the ideal way to do this was sort
of random it wasn't completely random
but it wasn't as neat and orderly as as
a as you would think but what really
took off was that the same the same
notion how to connect if computers was
so applicable to other things such as
Airlines the stock market the formation
of galaxies atoms for it though that the
same math applied to so many different
things that there's really
revolutionized the field of trying to
understand brain development not so much
as which junk gets bigger or smaller but
how they're all connected so it's like
the different parts of the brain are
like letters of the alphabet and as you
go from a baby to an adult
the letters get formed into words the
words into sentences the sentences in
the paragraphs and so on but this new
type of math has really helped us now go
back to old data this is an example of
childhood schizophrenia really rare 1
500 is common as adults it's FN yet and
we look at the the old ways of just
swinging which chunk of the brain is
bigger or small or a different shape not
really able to tell them apart very well
but when we look at how the different
parts of the brain are communicating how
they're connected then with this exact
same brain scan the same input now we
can just separate schizophrenia from
controlled I've still the group level
males and females young from old but
it's a very new excitingly looking at
things one of the ideas of the fire
together wire together grow together was
that if we're looking at electrical
activity and thousands of a second or
lead flow in three to five seconds or
across decades we all we see the same
pattern of connectivity in terms of that
different parts of the brain are are
connected so it's a very robust finding
and now we can go back and look at
relationships between how the brain is
connected and things like a vocabulary
ability where two parts of the brain
that row together in terms of that the
change of our time is a tighter predicts
ability for vocabulary the other way
that the brain matures is by becoming
more specialized and so these are both
gardening metaphors what you have is
arborization my our verve the latin root
/ tree like extra branches twigs in
which not not more neurons that s pretty
much I'm pretty stable around the time
of birth but we have these growth of
arborization more connections and anna
pruning process then we're only the
useful and good one survived so both our
ization pruning they constantly
occurring throughout life it's not like
all of childhood is building up in all
of adolescents eliminating but
unbalanced we see this change and so
this is
Lando's painting that building the brain
is not like a painting that you this I
use this example because this on the
right is often looks like a brain trip
too many people in terms of a side
section the temporal lobes of the brain
it's that's been written about quite a
bit and then this is described as the
original sin apps neuroscience humor but
it's not like that that's not how the
brain is built it's much more like
Michelangelo's other artistic outlet of
softly in terms of we start with a block
of granite eliminate certain components
to create the masterpiece and so it is
one-two punch of overproduction followed
by selected elimination that that is how
the brain becomes complex it's really
not even just the brain it's how
everything in nature the complexity
arises from this one to process over
produce fierce competition you know
fight it out and then select the
elimination it's the engine of evolution
but what we find is that different parts
of the brain would sure it and
specialized at different rates and the
part of the brain the prefrontal cortex
is amongst the latest to reach about
levels not to like 25 to 30 I seem like
really late when we started these
studies we're always so we follow people
till they're 16 or 18 x 16 they're
already winning medals in the Olympics
that are already quite bad well well
we'll play it safe will overshoot go to
1825 wasn't even on our radar screen we
somewhat joked that if you go to the
airport to rent a car you have 225
really high insurance race me like oh no
wonder in Euro science is suffering
hurts us all the vests no scientists and
we can be making progress but it didn't
really go away in terms of like I'm that
at this age your your immune systems of
best resistance with cancer reaction
times trauma street heat and cold almost
anything you measured you got your copy
of your game but morbidity and mortality
go up three hundred percent so number
one car accidents on two and three
suicide homicide but all the top ten
related to judgment decision making and
so this really became a theme that the
brain is still under construction
through not just through the teen years
but well into the 20s but again good
thing or we wouldn't be here in terms of
the you know this ability to to stay
flexible to be able to adapt to change
is essential for our survival species
but this is an aspect where it's not as
good as it's going to get but things
like long-range planning controlling
their impulses having to organize and
implement plans and so this is a part of
the brain right here that is still under
construction for quite some time and
it's such an important you know part for
the behaviors that we see it's involved
in in things like like time travel so
humans can imagine the past in the
future integrating things from the
present kind of a darkening but things
like counterfactuals what-ifs we can
play out different scenarios in our mind
and we get better and better at this you
look into our 60s more sort of scenarios
can be run in our mind but a philosopher
Karl Popper said this wonderfully that
are hypotheses die in our step that we
don't have to fall out of trees and you
know you know I could eaten by animals
into so we can run these scenarios in
our mind and this is part of what the
prefrontal cortex can help with not by
itself but as part of a node in a
circuit it's also what gets clogged up
when you try to do multi tasking so when
you do have people do things like
driving while while talking on cell
phone things this is a part of the brain
that's even more vulnerable for
adolescents this is still being
developed and so multitasking is even
greater risk for most sorts of things
but there are many applications on for
this in terms of this up for voting for
making decisions about marriage about
sex about career or box offices a lot of
these decisions and
happen before before age 25 and we need
to understand what influences in terms
of what we do as a parent as a teacher
effects of medicines video games
exercise that all these things they
could affect this one two punch old
producing followed by a selected
elimination the last point I'm going to
make about the brain maturation that
it's not just a matter of the prefrontal
areas being under construction for a
longer time that it's also related to a
part of the brain called limbic system
or the ward circuitry that is activated
at the time of puberty they have a lot
of common receptors or so around age 10
to 13 we have this explosion of
developed in these areas that intensify
our passions fax aggression social
social drives and this kind of gap in
between the early maturing limbic
regions and the later maturing frontal
regions account for many of the
behaviors that we see and the currency
for these behaviors is dopamine in terms
of making a good decision pleasure
dopamine goes up reinforces those
connections bad decision pain and
happiness displeasure dopamine goes down
don't don't use those connections don't
keep those connections and the dopamine
is where it's a primitive type of
molecule it's about the many things
movement motivation we were not being
but also addiction so all things that
are addiction they hijack this dopamine
may work system and in fact everything
that's addicted from drugs to shopping
sexo even things like sleep and hunger
they all affect the same fundamentally
work system and increased dopamine and a
small part of the bank of nuclear
companies but I think it's my addictions
can be so challenging to treat it
bypasses the frontal cortex bypasses
thinks it's a very fundamental attack on
our reward systems so there are the
adolescents are particularly at risk
during this time when the reward systems
being fine-tuned
being being set and so there's a lot of
a work a lot of research now kind of
trying to understand why adolescence is
a vulnerable time for addictions and
what to do about it same things for
eating disorder why does even this order
it only happen after puberty that it's
related to this ignition of rewards
reward systems but we understand how
these changes are happening the dopamine
system it might help us address many of
these illnesses I'm so just about out of
time it just a few things about the
influences we are looking at twins the
kind of nature and not nature or nurture
but nature nurture type of questions
what parts of the brain are related to
genes and environment at different times
and one of the findings that surprises a
bit that there's this lasting echo
really environments where even amongst
totally healthy twins that we can tell
30 years later which twin was heavier
than than the other twin but the most
fundamental thing we found was that it's
a moving target different parts of the
brain are more heritable at different
ages and this really is needs to be
addressed in all these studies of
looking at jeans and brain and behavior
because the answer changes things that
are the changing in teenagers become
more heritable in adolescence which
surprised us in terms of the brain
active moves more similar even though
each twin has different environments but
these are the same brain regions
involved in schizophrenia and depression
and things that emerged during during
this time the genes matter this is a one
of the most profound and what a
four-fold increase in violent crime a
time increased vested for murder 50
times risk for being a death row I made
it the last one but but of course this
is the Y gene and male-female
differences which is such a sale who's
better in the
of it but it's a huge clue and for the
biologies everything I study as a child
to kya tryst is different between boys
and girls men and women and to try to
understand how these differences in
healthy typical male females might
relate to the illnesses but the brains
of males and females overwhelmingly more
alike than different but these subtle
differences do do have do have an effect
and I'm going to skip a few slides here
just to get to the point that sometimes
these differences are you know really
overplayed you know men are from Mars
Venus and board games he's planetary
style differences where this is where
I'm from in North Dakota there are
differences but to me they're much more
subtle so it's more like men are from
North Dakota women are in South Dakota
the differences are real there's subtle
they're important but um that it's at a
group level and most of these
differences are only in the path of
brain development not in the snapshots
in time so much of what we learned for
differences between males and females
healthy and ill relating to cognition or
behavior we really need to look at the
path of brain development not just a
snapshot my final point though is that
this plasticity confers on
vulnerabilities most mental illnesses
emerge during this time not a few not a
lot over fifty percent and so this is in
a critical time not not everything but
there's a lot of of clues here to
understand why if you born at the risk
for NE a-- why does it wait till you're
a teenager to show up or depression or
anxiety something eating disorder but at
everything not autism not ADHD not
Alzheimer's and so we're very interested
in this interaction between typical
changes for things like schizophrenia
all the findings gets a pena could be
predicted if you said what happens if
regular teen development goes too far
and this predicts the findings that you
see in schizophrenia and
a lot of things that for adolescence
it's not really an illness but they're
very important unplanned pregnancies
sexually transmitted diseases motor
accidents being arrested and put in jail
life decisions and so adolescence is
that kind of this idea is a path empty
half full adolescents would say well
people yes not only half empty but the
waters dirty that glass is cracked
unless your fault but that that's not
all true there's enormous opportunity
for people in to harness this this
change ability to have many different
life courses but most teens get through
this most adolescents get through they
do well they become productive adults
but if we understand this ability of the
brain to change and if we can harness
this we can do a lot to improve the
lives of abuse and families so I'd like
to thank you very much for your
attention and look forward to answering
their questions if I can thank you for
that informative presentation before it
gets started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind the audience
how to ask questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button in the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can the
first question is has the mouse to human
innate immune system model of
receptor-mediated self like
differentiation been linked from
fossilized teeth to ecological
adaptation via brain development let me
know if you want so one of the UM should
I should I answer by text or one of the
challenges of going from mouse models to
humans is the prefrontal cortex itself
which is uniquely human it's what most
difference between us and bonobos and
chimpanzees are rather close our other
close relatives and so this has been one
of the challenges in
terms of the part of the brain that is
the most interesting during adolescence
the prefrontal cortex which mature is
the latest which is most different
between man and mouse is particularly
hard you know to study during these
adolescent years do you get more
neurogenesis from exercise and teen
brains compared to the young or older
adults two signs of neurogenesis what a
great question and one of its unknown in
terms of whether there's a pronounced up
you know fact during adolescence but
even with with aging so for Alzheimer's
disease dementia the most effective
treatment right now is exercise and it's
not just sort of the general stuff oh
yeah we should all exercise eat well and
get enough sleep in stop that it has
direct and unknown mechanisms on
neurogenesis who intermediaries like
insulin growth factor genes and and so
it's a really active area right now in
terms of looking at physical activity in
school systems and interventions for
depression or anxiety and it's one of
the things that we're going to be
focusing on in this new large study
called ABCD adolescent brain cognitive
development looking at twelve thousand
nine year olds as they go through the
second decade of life but I think what's
really been fascinating recent years is
that the effect of exercise on learning
and on brain help it's getting stronger
and stronger and and it almost seemed
like in some ways it was up kind of all
X unscientific rates like oh yeah
everybody knows we should exercise more
but we're understanding much more of a
direct and measurable link between body
and brain in that respect and for me
it's actually one of the most you know
exciting areas and and now with things
like Fitbit and with other sensors and
stuff we can get a much better one
location of physical activity of
adolescents and for the first time we'll
be able to answer this question you know
with more data in terms that we can
really look at the effects of movement
exercise on mental illness on health on
cognition on on behavior but it's a type
of question in regards to the different
levels of white matter and males and
females was this in one particular area
or was a uniform all around really good
question so before we used to think that
it was more like uniform in terms of but
now we see that certain parts of the
brain have more Energon male receptors
other parts of more estrogen female
receptors and that it's a moving target
in terms of development and so the
question is just exact same question we
were wondering about um but this is an
example so whether you have early
puberty or late puberty and it has such
a broad range from nine to fifteen is
all healthy you know typical puberty for
something so important you would think
nature might have constrained it a
little bit tighter but whether you have
at early cubed or late puberty doesn't
affect your abilities on the Rubik's
Cube you're solving these problems on
doing many math problems or things that
doesn't appear to be as affected by
puberty and by male-female differences
other things are affected more in the
decision-making mouth and so if your
mail and things that lead to sax leading
to your progress are we be more
motivating for females social standing
other other aspects so for certain types
of tests and certain types of
decision-making male female differences
are stronger for other cognitive things
they're not and so we're starting to
separate this out a bit but one of the
things that we're trying to understand
is that things that are more common in
boys are all at birth early in life
ADHD dyslexia autism's you know 442 1721
mail if more severe really different
it's not you know not not a little bit
bit more and then things that are more
common in females depression and panic
attacks and anxiety are only more common
after puberty and it is puberty is not a
trial but it's literally after doing so
that's that's a big clue in terms of why
these changes and so from you know mouse
models and other things we see that that
the hormones will affect stress response
in in females but not male mice and so
so we're seeing some of these
differences in terms of even things like
if you throw people out of a plane if
you throw min out then their memory will
be better for those instances and
females not so this kind of these kind
of like given parachutes actually but
but these differences that we're just
starting to appreciate a bit more but we
have to be careful because
overwhelmingly more like than different
and so for schools i want to say oh it's
like you know teach girls this way um
use it or lose it did some teens grow
like a bamboo tree or all grow in tight
temporal chronological limits and it's
I'm not very tight you know temporal
type of limits and so um this idea of
overproduction and selective elimination
of fighting it out and is very very
powerful in terms of the use it or lose
it I think holds throughout life but
particularly well it's obviously
throughout life is in childhood it's
very powerful but in adolescents as well
and if we can understand when you know
to practice sports or or different
cognitive skills and stop it's very
powerful but the ability of the brain to
change based on the use of music is
really powerful it's really that the
genes and our biology set pretty broad
you know playing field but what we do at
the brain
really makes a huge difference in what
it ends up to being specialized in has
her work address the effect of amino
acid substitutions on social brain
development and effects on behavior
during life history transitions so
that's an area that I haven't personally
been involved in and I have to do some
research you know to see it it'd be it'd
be interesting in terms of in some ways
you know with the social cognition this
was so broad them so much of the brain
is dedicated to social interactions but
that in in nematode worms and simple
systems 11 tweaked 10 meter asset can
actually change them from being social
to not social so that was one of the
most intriguing findings their recent
years we thought this is going to be so
complicated it'll be a thousand genes
and everyone contributing a very tiny
amount and and so it doesn't always work
that way sometimes a you know amino
acids which that seems you know such as
low level molecular change can actually
have profound differences in very very
complicated behaviors the most
complicated of all behavior social
reactions and there's there's so many
gaps between you know molecules and and
cells and circuits and behavior that the
future people that can cross these
doubts are going to be super valuable to
understand molecular biology but also
social cognition I think it'd be a
really fun area for younger people to be
involved in
forgiving stress the pattern have
changed in the amygdala and hippocampus
can be different while HIPAA the
hippocampus can shrink in volume the am
a Dalek an increase in size can you
explain the underlying mechanism for
this different pattern of change the
hippocampus is very responsive to stress
and cortisol levels and that it's an
interesting part of the brain in that it
generates new brain cells after birth
there's only a few areas that do that
the olfactory system of part of the
cerebellum and this part of the
hippocampus so hippocampus is very
responsive to the environment it's sort
of involved in memory acquisition
storage retrieval it needs to sort of
stay flexible in terms of it needs to
stay responsive to the environment and
so so many illnesses that have stress
like depression sylvania is up it's a
very common target to be affected by by
these these sort of changes and and it
has both male and female home receptors
but has a preponderance of estrogen
contacted receptors the amygdala is more
involved in what's important in the
environment it's not just sort of
threats but sort of what's salient
what's really important for the brain to
attend to and it's also a built to
change a lot during adolescence in terms
up with the changes in hormones and
different priorities in terms of
reproducing in terms of becoming
independent of needing to the aggressive
at times to protect you and your loved
ones and so both the amygdala
hippocampus are very very active in
decision-making in what the brain
focuses on in the environment and we're
just getting a early understanding of
what actually happens in terms of of
making the changes in the size of these
structures but they're surprisingly
dynamic during adolescence
thinking about teen brains as a work in
progress what is your point of view
about trying to improve PFC function
with prescribed medications could it
bypass the natural progression and
create areas that won't be connected in
the long term the interesting question
of that we when we think about the
prefrontal cortex being under
construction for for a long time to try
to fix that to try to make that you know
better I think it's the wrong you know
the wrong way to go that the people in
the functions they are really important
for success in life I'm self-regulation
doing the hard thing waiting for longer
larger later Awards versus sooner
smaller is one of the things that's very
predictable as we go from childhood
adolescence to adulthood we are much
better at waiting for larger later
rewards as the prefrontal cortex matures
but this idea up sooner is better is one
of the things that the biology and the
neuroscience has really questioned that
is it always better to do things early
and it has this has huge implications
for the educational system in terms of
countries like Finland teach reading and
naturally seven verses countries that
teach at age four and then in Finland
the students actually end up being
better and many measures by age 11 in
terms up than that earlier isn't always
better and so I think that those are the
balance here in terms of if I would you
try to improve prefrontal connections
and maturation I would much rather focus
on behavior in terms of meditation of
being good at a sport or am useless
mineral or school I'm using perhaps you
know computer interventions video games
or software that can help improve our
ability to delay gratification to find
patterns pattern recognition other huge
important skill up for the future but of
all the interventions for me
aight medicines would be the last you
know in terms of i think that the brain
is very responsive to the demands that
we ask of it during this time and that
perhaps you know someday with the right
amount of data because they yeah this
actually you know medicine might help in
this area but um i would i would
recommend a thousand things first before
going to a medicine intervention but but
i think im so key if we could understand
sorry sorry about the little cutting you
off there um computer to that um i would
like to once again thanks dr. dean for
his presentation do you have any final
comments dr. Gabe to and more on this
positive note because it seems they get
bashed a lot and even amongst teens and
solidly they consistently underrate
themselves on their contributions to
community on the positive aspects and
that this is a time that is just loaded
with the opportunity that if we can
challenge the brain in the right ways
it's going to adapt incredibly and so
even though I concede this is a time of
vulnerability to depression anxiety
substance abuse some psychosis that we
don't lose sight of the positive aspect
this is also a great time for for
positive change
thanks again today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
September 2016 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to afford that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye